you are really confident about your
story confident ones you tell everything
they're like yeah it was like this they
lie a lot of times too you
you're the only one who looked at the
other girls to tell a story they just
looked at us the whole time
so you mentioned that this was in 2012
for the Winter Olympics 2010 right okay
so you said 2012. oh you also said at
the time you were 22. yeah and if you
were born in 1986 you would have been 24
in 2010 or 26 in 2012. so you wouldn't
have been 22.
some things didn't line up but I'm going
between these two I'm gonna have to
disagree I'm gonna cast my vote for Kate
I'm gonna go with the Italian story
[Music]
well I feel good I'm still batting below
500 but uh yeah it's it's good to win
one for once I needed this